[Musique]
à loos est bon dit oui oui bonsoir j'ai
ensemble j'ai entendu votre annonce sur
la voie du leader oui
après savoir c'étaient des gars ont
cherché un nom je cherche pas des
poupons pardon je ne cherche pas des
poupons c'est pas des pompons non c'est
de couper les poupées et ben brik ce que
je m'attarde est résulté rien qu'à les
bonnes choses à revoir
ça fait longtemps que vous aimez les
femmes
oui assez depuis l'âge de 14 ans est la
première fois ça vous a fait quoi comme
impression assez bizarre j'avais vu tant
de moi et puis en réfléchissant j'ai
trouvé ça super monde pourquoi je sais
pas ce que c'était la première fois que
ça m'arrive est donc je ne savais pas à
quoi m'attendre
puis c'était une découverte pour moi
dont je pouvais pas je sais pas quand
mais attendent vraiment je sais pas mais
vous avez dit honte
bah oui parce que la première fois que
ça vous arrive vous demandez pourquoi
vous avez fait ça et puis vous le savez
pas nouveau on sait pas nous mêmes moi
je sais que je vais pas c'est pourquoi
j'avais fait sur des bus c'est qu'après
que quand j'ai vu que j'avais besoin de
ça c'est là que j'ai compris que
vraiment j'avais besoin d'une personne
qu'ils sachent au mois mai mais est un
homme ça peut pas être tendre ainsi un
homme ça peut être tendre ça peut être
doux ça peut être qu alain mais c'est
pas un homme qui va me donner la
tendresse maternelle tu me manques je
pense pas tant qu'à faire
est-ce que vos parents le savent
non juste mon père c'est tout
je lui ai dit une fois comme ça et là
pas été étonnée je pense pas vous avez
quel âge
moi j'ai 22 ans est-ce que passer des
petites annonces comme ça par téléphone
c'est pas un peu comment dire
ben si vous voulez c'est plus facile de
rencontrer des gens en passant des
annonces que d'aller draguer par exemple
qu'une femme devant chose que je n'ai
jamais fait vous êtes né ou chez nous au
liban beyrouth vous séduisez beaucoup je
sais des offres vous séduisez les
garçons et les filles à le 2 vous est
bisexuelle ouais et pourquoi les filles
et les garçons
je ne sais pas c'est pas mal de monde et
c'est à ma mère c'est laid comme ça tu
peux pas se faisait vous arrivez pas
choisir entre meinau le naulleau s'est
pas depuis mon enfance je me sens comme
ça sa progression je veux où je veux pas
ce qu elles sont commandées chacun d'eux
williams excellent e chacun d'eux ou
bisexuel il ya des gens qui du coup vers
sata auto moi je suis né comme ça parce
que les plus jeunes enfants j'aime les
femmes et le garçon quand je vois des
cuisses aux dessins de femmes au secours
nous causera des garçons qui fait nous
pouvons voir dans le garçon qui veut pas
de poster au fond
j'étais toujours attirée par les filles
aussi parce que même en rade à nous
frapper quand est ce qu'à l'âge de 13
ans arrête que la maman de grade à
l'alto fable maman de marie à la laddh
pas de gueuler du mot google gardent bas
du col de velefique as tu veux déjà
atone hdmi cec déjà un voyage quoi c'est
pas mais quand est ce que ça a commencé
la première fille je me fais j'avais été
tellement jeune j'avais 6 ans quand
j'étais à l'école c'est très grand pour
mon âge tu ne me donnes 9 ans et j'avais
6 ans à peu près j'insiste à cet enjeu
weezer est le premier bassin depuis mon
enfance je me souviens pas comme la
première fois je sens qu'un garçon m'a
touché j'avais 5 ans vous n'êtes pas un
peu vicieux entre est peut-être trop
cire vous avez quel âge
en vieillissant vous pensez vous allez
continuer comme ça longtemps moi j'ai
veillé ça va jamais de la vie
le jour que je sens je suis vieux je me
suicide
je continue comme ça ça aurait fait
comme les autres comme les autres
vieillard ce qu'on fait mais toujours
pas être [ __ ] à la limite à la faire il
voulait finir comment moi je fais avec
un père de famille quoi voulez vous
marier
ah oui je voulais avoir des enfants
seraient faisait déjà un an et demi un
enfant et lui colle et demi elle est en
route
moi ma première histoire d'amour était
une histoire avec une fille une fille de
l'école qui n'était pas une economics
moi j'avais 10 ans elle en avait 13 et
et puis l'histoire d'amour a commencé un
soir d'orage ou sa mère de ne pas
laisser entrer sous la pluie et on a
dormi dans le même lit et puis voilà ça
a commencé comme ça fait durer longtemps
ça a duré six ans ils vous ont gardé un
bon souvenir de l'histoire d'amour oui
surtout du début au début c'était
vraiment quelque chose de merveilleux
c'était la découverte d'une sensualité
mais c'était aussi très très riche sur
le plan affectif intellectuel on était
vraiment pleine effervescence on a voulu
changer le monde et c'était très beau et
j'ai vécu cette histoire en toute
innocence et un jour on était en train
de s'embrasser dans la salle de bain
chez nous et ma mère a ouvert la porte
et elle nous a vus alors là c'était
c'était horrible elle s'est mise à
pleurer
mais comme je l'avais mise au monde une
fille normale est bon c'est là que le
mot normal est tombé et donc on s'est
posé la question si on était anormal est
ce que vous savez que votre maman est
bisexuelle oui ça vous gêne pas
non ça me gêne pas passer même je pense
que si je l'avais appris avant sa mort
est pas pas gêner s'était pas donc elle
m'a pas dit ça comme une révélation tu
sais ma chérie je vais dire quelque
chose en fait
quand je suis avec des femmes s'est tue
pas comme on commet aussi quand j'étais
petit j'ai même plus tard j'ai eu des
expériences aussi avec des filles mais
je suis jamais tombée amoureuse d'une
femme
je ne me vois pas vraiment amoureuse
d'une femme comme comme je peux l'être
d'un homme même si aussi bon pour un
contact physique ou finalement que ce
soit une femme ou un homme qui me
caresse c'est pas grave quoi je vais pas
une grande différence
mais les battements de coeur et tout ça
moi c'est plus vers les 1 ou encore
[Musique]
vous avez accepté de parler à visage
découvert pourquoi concernant la
bisexualité est bien parce que je pense
que c'est un problème qui est chuchoté
actuellement et qui va être bientôt
poser publiquement dans des conférences
qu'est ce que vous trouvez avec un homme
que vous ne pouvez pas avec une femme
j'ai mon semblable
c'est les bâtis comme moi il a un
système génital comme le mien il est il
et il a une zone du sternum au nombril
qui reçoit des émotions il a dans le
visage en correspondance volontairement
ou involontairement des choses qui
passent entre son émotion et sa
sexualité
si vous êtes arrivé d'être amoureux d'un
homme je ne sais pas bien le terme si
vous voulez j'ai trouvé avec un homme
quelquefois un confort intellectuel et
d'autres fois une une souffrance avoué
clairement avoué sans qu'elle soit
morbide et déconcertante
j'ai été sensible à ça je vois pas
beaucoup d'autres choses pour l'instant
là et vous avez rencontré beaucoup de
femmes il vous faut aussi les hommes
pourquoi parce que je veux tout je
voudrais fumée je veux tout et tout je
veux tout dire je veux tout ce que peut
souhaiter dans l'épanouissement de soi
même
actuellement je veux m'épanouir et même
jusqu'au bout tout blanc et digne
vous savez que votre période vie
sexuelle je suis content même autant
content parce que bon j'ai un père pour
les gens j'ai un père spéciales et puis
c'est toujours bon à prendre que c'est
toujours agréable
puis comme moi je le suis aussi au moins
cent ans on s'entend pour cela des
points communs alors si côté jules je
crois pas non c'est pas contagieux c'est
c'est normal jeu du c'est normal c'est
héréditaire non plus
peut-être sur moi il ya une hérédité
quelque part mais bon il suffit pas se
poser la question
vous aimez plus les femmes que les
hommes ou les hommes que les femmes et
les femmes plus que les hommes
ton corps à ce qu'une femme je vais je
vais plus loin je vis la relation avec
une femme beaucoup plus plus fort je le
fais plus de choses avec les familles
qui se passionne beaucoup plus je
m'ennuie moi je m'ennuie moins long
terme si on doit rester longtemps semblé
moins qu'une femme pourquoi il vous faut
un homme en plus d'une femme je croise
une question d'équilibré avant tout j'ai
besoin de ça pour être bien l'équilibré
sarr valorise la relation avec la femme
est ce qui vous est arrivé d'être
amoureux d'un homme
enfin je le suis un peu en ce moment je
me suis un peu mais je n'arrive pas à me
le dire je n'arrive pas à dire j'aime un
homme jaime telle personne
parce que bon j'arrive beaucoup plus
facilement le dire à une femme et à le
penser que penser d'une femme mais bon
faut admettre que c'est vrai voilà ce
que c'est vrai
florence est ce que vous avez été
jalouse du fait qu'il est malin garçons
n'ont pas du tout pas du tout justement
ça me gêne en moins où ça me gênerait
moins par rapport à un homme que par
rapport à une femme je me dis que jean
marc hautbois un homme en général peut
être plus entraîner dans son cas par une
femme que par un homme donc c'est pour
ça qu'une relation avec un homme ne me
dérange pas qu'avec une femme je sais
très bien que peut-être ça peut ça peut
sembler mai et à ce moment là donc qu'il
ait plus rien entre nous il attendrait
son la trouve et qui moi je la trouve
plus avec les hommes qu'avec les femmes
si on parle du mot tendresse la être
tendre avec quelqu'un réellement
sincèrement sans froufrous ni quoi que
ce soit avec avec un homme je suis
beaucoup plus tendre et c'est
extrêmement rare c'est extrêmement je ne
suis comme j'ai une relation avec un
homme s'est on peut parler de moments
très tendres on peut parler de tendresse
que je lui donne la tendresse que je
ressens mais pas dans vie sexuelle
spontanée chose comme sonne tout en
harmonie
[Musique]
moi j'ai été pendant longtemps habité
par l' envie d'être une femme
j'en suis guéri depuis trois quatre ans
seulement
j'ai très très envie d'être une femme
bon déjà parce que j'ai côtoyés
énormément de femmes et puis peut-être
je n'ai pas eu mon père assez souvent et
ainsi de suite
[Musique]
vous avez gainage très 25 cents vous
voyez que ça va durer longtemps
je n'espère pas j'en suis sûr parce que
j'allais tout faire pour que ça continue
comme ça puisque je me sens bien
[Musique]